- So Magic Mike 3, it's happening right?
I heard that it's happening.
- Yes.
(audience cheers)
- Okay.
You were trying to keep it from us Sir.
- (Channing laughs) I really did not.
- You tried not to do it.
- I, you know, if I'm moving here.
- Oh my gosh.
- If I'm, oh God.
- That's amazing.
- No, no, don't put that up.
- I would put that,
If I worked out and looked like that,
I would put it up everywhere.
- Trust me, that might be
the reason why I didn't want
to do the third one, it's
'cause I have to look like that.
- So you don't work out
regularly all the time?
- No, but it's hard to look like,
even if you do work out
to be that kind of in shape,
- To be that kind of toned?
- It's not natural.
- Do you have to eat like so well?
- Yeah, you have to, well is not even,
that's not even healthy.
You have to starve yourself.
- Oh my God.
- I don't think when you're
that lean, it's actually
healthy for you.
- See, health is dangerous,
that's why.
- It is, it's true.
- (Kelly laughs) I'm just kidding.
- New public service announcement folks.
Health is not good for you.
- New PSA.
This is why I don't work out.
(Channing laughs)
I am just trying to save people here.
No, but what is it like
getting into shape for that?
Like is it that kind of hell?
- Yeah, I mean, which truly,
I don't know how people that working
nine to five actually stay in shape
because it's my full-time
job and I can barely do it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But it is,
if you work out twice a day
you have to eat completely
right, at a certain time.
It's a specific thing.
- It's a talent to be
able to do that as well.
Because even in like,
when I have like vacation time,
I'm like this is the time.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna do it.
- Holy.
- No.
- I don't do it.
- I fluctuate like almost,
it was a lot more when I was younger
but now I can't get it off, so as easy.
So now I'm, fluctuate like 15 pounds,
but I used to fluctuate like 30 pounds.
- Age is not fun.
- No.
- Yeah.
- And why when it takes like, I don't know
two months to get really lean
but in like three days
you can lose it.
- You can ruin it.
- It's gone.
- Yeah (Kelly laughs).
- I was like, what, what happened?
It was just the weekend.
- What's the thing
that you miss most?
- Yeah.
- Like what's the thing you miss most?
- The thing I miss most
probably is like salt.
- Oh.
- Like when you need to get really close
to the, like the day where you gotta
be butt naked on screen.
- Yeah.
- And, and it,
- Those days aren't for everyone.
- No.
(Kelly laughs)
- Salt is just like, you
know, it goes, you just,
everything just tastes like,
- Yeah.
- I don't know, tastes
like water, it's nothing.